attention on va parler d'eux photo 1 10
photos à nice et qui bon lui alors c'est
qui euh je vais venir sur la télévision
sur m6
c'est une nouvelle assistante c'est pas
un peu tard non pas après pas mal aller
je prends j'aimerais avoir sciemment
quand même moi aussi je sonne on blandin
antoine blondin trèbes badens et le
nouvel expert de recherche appartement
ou maison apparemment il va avoir un
appel de mathieu dorment au grill veut
déménager
voilà six mois sachez que mathieu ne
demande qu'à vichy et quand j'ai un
doute je reviens avec un ami pour visser
de l'après ben ali
c'est une maison et des pré visites et
de la cave aux contes succès sur les
réseaux sociaux
hier soir ça fait 2 millions de
téléspectateurs recherche appartement ou
maison vous a fait un petit récap de
l'émission d'hier c'est parti hier soir
sur m6 ce nouvel épisode de recherche
appartement ou maison
un épisode marque free par la présence
d'un nouvel agent immobilier qui a
provoqué pas mal de réactions sur
twitter tu faire un épisode durant
lequel ils ont ouvert très sport
parti
[Musique]
ce monsieur a essayé d'en placer une
mais sa femme de la faim calculé
pourquoi vous êtes là bas on est tous
les extras fillon travaille pour les
nations unies une dame avait un léger
toc avec les placards et ça c'est un peu
vu moi j'ai rangé tobis elle préfère ça
compte des gens très vite sinon les
agents immobiliers se prennent de plus
en plus pour des beaux gosses
regardez cette arrivée
[Musique]
un jeune homme qui cherche un appart n'a
pas été trop relou avec la vue moi ce
que je voulais c'est à voir
voilà une vue dégagée si je peux avoir
un point chambre ses hôtes avec une vue
avec la vue qu'on a derrière et ce
client n'a pas pris de gants avec son
agent immobilier c'est vrai que tu as
terrasse à la canebière mais j'avoue que
je m'en fous un petit peu bilan
d'audience pour ce nouveau numéro de
recherche appartement ou maison 2
millions de téléspectateurs
c'est parce que vous en pensiez vous
laisser pas mal est pas mal du tout nous
y affine le plaisir de voir des belles
personnes aussi physiquement à la télé
bastien le contenu il ça fait plaisir
parce qu'on regarde
bonjour